[Music]
in making it last news making map
emitted by dr. who who women share how
they turned one-night stands into
relationships how that was wonderful
the only one-night stands I ever had the
dude wanted the relationship oh he was a
player girl I did I told him a friend I
was like I'm in my [ __ ] phase right now
I don't want any relationships about
that when guys want to be in a
relationship they thought I was just
saying that no [ __ ] must be that good
[Music]
I've got a vise grip on their [ __ ] it's
probably because you weren't thirsty and
then the guy was like oh [ __ ] turn away
rebirth psychology damn maybe if I was
trying to reverse psychology I feel
really good about myself feelings for
you he's like it actually ended up being
annoying cuz they wanted to stay in
cuddle after and I was like no you go
home look bad you won't play out
you're like a real true John I just
didn't want the intimacy like I just
want the day [ __ ] me from a [ __ ] they
use them like a little tissue you say go
away yeah you're the first one that tell
me that you love me and I just kept
telling them like we're just trying to
have fun but then I started having
feelings how fast ladies bar love thank
you
what the [ __ ] that was actually pretty
soft it was really fast how fast weeks
months it was like weeks do over the
phone did he know you're a big [ __ ]
just kidding but I said little Dino
you're so pretty pretty with whatever
bean thing that he calls you but it
always works okay so for you guys
one-night stand
is it like when you meet someone and
that same day [ __ ] them that's how I
would classify it a lot of nice dad
hello those okay they're pretty fun or
it could also be like an acquaintance
that you know them from somewhere but
you weren't like super close as soon as
you have to work for
during if that counts cuz I think it
counts cuz it's not someone that like
I'm scared of ruining the relationship
with it's like oh but if you double up
on a one-night stand it's a [ __ ] buddy
though that's that's when it changes hmm
if you spend more than 24 hours on
trying to get laid with that person I
don't think it's a one-night stand
anymore - because you're working toward
the goal yeah
what if you'd never really saw this
person but then you guys [ __ ] when you
did and you don't really seem to [ __ ]
the [ __ ] body but you're not even like
talk to them a booty call my booty call
it's a booty call okay I think a
one-night stand
the what really defines it is the fact
that there you guys are just strangers
you guys were just meeting just the [ __ ]
and that is completely in and out of
each other's way as a band
boom yeah not already mingling in each
other's life I never had one-night stand
then yeah it's not that random co-worker
on the I did that it was like random
co-workers like people that I like I
never had one I hung out with a few
times even one I sounds like that and
now you're like oh she's a youtuber and
you go to a college show then you hook
up with one of the college girls and you
bound bingo
one-night stand but also can be groupie
say I thought it was just you had sex
one night same okay it was like you come
in and that person disappears and you go
off your other way you meet them that
same day it has to be like that thing I
think it's a 24-hour period rule
yep in and out oh damn oh no what do you
guys think huh I just want to hear the
rest of this article okay so the first
one is this girl who says that her first
one-night stand turn into a three-year
relationship oh that's that's kind of
like you know not really well no I turn
into a marriage girl because you you
guys knew each other and then it was uh
yeah so it doesn't count if I kind of
see how it's like one-night stand you
keep each other's numbers you find out
that you actually like each other and
you like [ __ ] each other yeah that's
kind of what these girls are talking
about ice that's pretty cool they had
met online he was visiting his family in
a town where she went to school so that
she saw him in person
Mark's blue she invited him to her place
she had no intention of seeing
again since she believing a lot
long-distance relationship but then the
next morning he joined her for breakfast
and then he joined her for lunch the dip
was good and then he also had a
personality yeah after he left town he
called her every single day and then a
month later he asked if she would be his
girl to go steady mm-hmm so then she was
like summer is only two months away why
not so then she stayed with him in
Boston for a while sounds romantic
yeah for the summer and then they dated
into her their senior year at college
and then they moved to New York together
but then they eventually broke up they
were fighting when they were living
together probably yeah
damn that came from the soul that's a
three years 10 long distance it was
better
[Laughter]
next check she says it's been almost a
year and a half since her one-night
stand
and she's amazed that it led to a fun
and healthy relationship she says that
her now girlfriend was this really cute
girl on her college driving class she
had no idea if she was a lesbian and
that she was too shy to talk to her in
class but then one night her neighbor
was throwing a party and then she saw
her talking to one of her friends and
since she already had a few drinks in
her she thought well what do I have to
lose so she approached her she found out
that the girl was bisexual and then the
end of hooking up and then she thought
that it was a one-night stand but then a
transition and two friends would benefit
mm-hmm and they've just kept it super
casual that's true because when I'm
thinking bisexual lesbian I'm king of
really hot girls to football player
ladies what do you think in college age
two and lingerie no lingerie lingerie
mm-hmm oh yeah and they just love having
sex all the time for goddamn reason
I just I just saw you buy I buy - let's
buy together back together yeah versus
laughs you both go on board - all right
let's call Walmart like how he ruins his
own fantasy oh gosh all right you won't
[ __ ] you got to do the [ __ ] cigarette
won't do the throat though this are you
by
[Laughter]
that [ __ ] got a cane and [ __ ] like 70
years old Lee one nights dad's can turn
into marriage talking about colleges she
says like a year and a half later just
cause what in 70 that's after they want
that's not doing live together that's
why oh I want a rom-com with that cast
oh hell yeah meal wrong
that'll be done it's real wrong and real
cool really raunchy
Netcom wrong so then she said that she
realized that her relationship might be
more than just physical when she had
trouble eating because her stomach was
filled with butter I just got it oh yeah
and then they started texting more and
then six six months later it was
Facebook official Oh
when that happens I keep trying to make
it official with us on Facebook to say
we're married but he's never on it so
it's always like request pending on my
Walkman I don't even know what my login
is I know that's why I could [ __ ]
pending not propose either no none of
that so are you really married all the
time how we did it oh yeah right any
event because if Esther than Facebook
well it's not official until it's
baseball before you redid the proposal
how did you do it I didn't do it you
just like you down to what no we're just
talking about it really I was like I
don't want to ring out on nothing and
then it was like yeah I believed it's
all cool get married never believed in
life he believed alive they get through
I'm like believer but none of us told
him not to yeah I did oh you did cuz I
don't remember what I would be like she
told you that bar
I don't remember maybe it went and one
year not the other yeah well sounds like
this penguins talking to me I would tell
go2 she's like nah girl I don't know
sometimes when guys hear another girl
that's not their girlfriend it's like oh
that's not my girlfriend that's you at
like my and sometimes they're right like
my one girlfriend always tries to
convince Steve that when I say no to
anal sex I really do like like want it
no that's completely false and he's like
I know but she's convinced that like she
loves anal sex a lot and so she's like I
know that if Nikki tried it she would
love it like don't listen to her
phishing Nick he's all like this isn't
weird she was like yeah you might enjoy
the anal sex
who likes BUTT STUFF steve-o called me
in front of her though to like he'll
like play along like he's trying to get
me and then later he'll be like nah I
don't want to do it yeah cuz of course
not yeah whatever
that's why it's just gonna feel great oh
that's gonna feel great he's gonna be
within special way anyway so the last
girl here she says that she was a
commitment-phobe
and she always joked that the only way
that she could ever be in a relationship
is this she didn't know she was in one
tight look what happened so she met a
guy at a bar I'm not married I don't
have a fab that's not my kid as follows
me
yeah I'm not pregnant yeah so she would
introduce herself using a fake name like
this is what she would usually do and
then she was quite leap tiptoe out of
his apartment after they hook up and
then she said for this one guy she a few
weeks after their hookup she bumped into
him at Starbucks and she was on her way
up the street when she heard a familiar
voice calling her fake name so she
turned around and there he was looking
as fine as ever and then as they talked
he looked down and see to look at her
Starbucks cup and I had her real name
written on it so then she said that her
weight her face lit on fire and then
that she confessed her web of lies to
him and then they ended up swapping
hilarious stories about the irrational
links they would go to to avoid
relationships and then that's when she
learned that he was just as screwed up
as she was that wasn't his real name
either if I thought I would have been
like you're a spy are you undercover
right now this sounds like a Wong foo
sketch with edge to it sounds like a
Matthew McConaughey movies like Bourne
Identity but the romance version it's
not mine either
oh it's like a Wong foo sketch with
nudity
yeah yeah so then she said that she felt
instantly comfortable with him and then
long story short they've been not
together for almost a year now I like
these things because it's like it's like
can you prove to me that love is real
and I'm not just being used as a
flashlight
[Laughter]
[Music]